ce soir je peux vous dire on a du gros
gros dossiers déjà gad je leur ai
démarré par toi mon chéri oui c'est que
j'aime beaucoup et je me suis plongé
dans ton album photo j'ai trouvé écoute
moi j'ai tué je me sens tellement bien
ce soir on a tellement bossé j'ai
tellement de dos je gémis de l'argent
personnel sur ce thème j'ai engagé des
équipes j'ai tout misé sur garde
regardez la bourgade en photo sega de
marocains regardez ça commence
[Applaudissements]
regardez on a gagné le mal et qui
déchantent du bateau en provenance du
marché
[Applaudissements]
ce ne sont que de vraies photos léchées
c'était l'avenir à l'époque rallier tous
les gars si vous êtes mauvaise langue
c'est la dernière fashion weeks on a
quatre qui est parti en turquie
regardez sa marque en europe et de
tarkan
[Musique]
on a gap qui a beaucoup voyagé on a gan
l'américain regarder l'amerloque
thumeries art
[Applaudissements]
à
bien si les cheveux de coûts nicolas est
un joueur cassini à dingo 72 72
regardez en a une autre bague l'italie
regardés comme des bourrins
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gad le breton c'est qu'on ait beaucoup
regardé en bretagne regarde et dit je le
dis à tous les bretons qui nous regarde
mon vrai nom c'est gad elmaleh qui sait
pour vous cette image quant à montrer la
photo de moi en noir et blanc jeu j'ai
tout de suite pensé à une image de toi
c'est émouvant c'est la seule image de
toi qu'on a si tu veux on a envie de
faire un don
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on a ses bons et ses propres et privé
entre le confessionnal mon père j'ai
péché c'est un fait mais en même temps
si mauvaises langues parce que cyril
malgré le fait qu'on soit adversaire ce
soir je te dois beaucoup de choses parce
que tu es un homme ouvert tué un homme à
qui on peut parler en tout moment je
suis un homme à qui on peut se confier
des équipes peuvent en témoigner
tu es là pour nous écouter et ça je
trouve que c'est
rien n'était mais on connaît exactement
ce que je pense que s'ils écoutent les
figer j'en ai une pour vous là j'ai pas
les filles où les mecs qui aiment les
beaux mecs
les mecs qui aiment les hommes sexy les
mecs qui aiment les hommes bien dans
leur peau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la lega celle là celle des échos celle
là je dois saluer les équipes parce qu'à
un moment donné ils m'ont dit on ne peut
pas lui faire ça et pour terminer cette
petite séquence un peu douloureuse pour
notre ami cyril il existe une tradition
dans la religion juive qui s'appelle la
bar mitzvah un petit peu l'équivalent de
la communion solennelle c'est le jour où
l'enfant devient n'ont pas d'eau les
sens mais adulte est admis par sa
communauté où normalement il doit
s'épanouir et normalement évoluer vous
laisse regarder ces images jean marais
tard ils sont bouleversés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bravo franchement natapei d'aluminium il
avait du lourd à il avait enfin ses
clients